why is it that a man can marry a woman
and maker Queen but a queen can't marry
a man and make him King
I wouldn't say that's natural I feel
like everybody's a queen and everybody's
a king
um from birth well if everyone was a
king or a queen why would a king or
queen be special
everybody's special you're special your
own believing yourself believe that you
can do anything you want to do you are a
queen you are a king from birth that is
how God made us God put us in this world
to be great you know everyone can't be
special everyone cannot be special
let me tell you something everybody is
special it's in you to dig deep and find
it some people don't dig deep in their
time that they have in life to get there
laughing like everybody's born to be
special you just have to figure out
what's special about you
you give it up no I feel like some
people don't special doesn't mean you're
not special no I think sometimes people
are average I think most why does my
life dim yours because if everyone's
special then no one's special it's not
true yeah because if you're special you
have to be different than other people
otherwise you're just average
everybody's special in their way I'm not
saying that everybody's the same I said
everybody's special in their way just
because okay you're special you like I
don't know what you like you might like
rock you might like this I'm special I
like totally different things that
doesn't make me less special yeah but
then there's still a million other
people that have the same like their own
things too all of us don't like the same
combination I think it's kind of like a
combination line we don't have the same
combination I think it's like
narcissistic to think you're like
special like I I feel like that's
narcissistic no you should feel like
you're special women tend to overvalue
themselves while men tend to undervalue
themselves
because
Okay so
as men when we grow up we have friends
that you know tease us and Bully us like
oh man your nose is big as hell you know
like they tell us these things that you
know to women it might sound demeaning
but to us they're giving us a reality
check so from a young age we grew up
getting reality checks constantly in a
joking manner you know your friends are
gonna joke with you and tease you and I
think on the other hand women they get
more Praises as they grow up so they
grow up all this time through you know
teenage years into adulthood and then
you wonder now when somebody actually
tell you like hey your nose is kind of
big and you're like I haven't been told
that my whole life well I've never been
lying do you think that do you think
that men tend to insult each other and
not mean it while women tend to
complement each other and not mean it
100 that pretty much is what I was
saying like you summed it up that's
that's pretty much it men insult each
other and it's more of a endearment like
man you ugly as hell boy you can't talk
to me whereas a girl tells like oh girl
you look good and then like no she
doesn't like you know that kind of stuff
so yeah you summed it up pretty good
it's crazy it's crazy I I call them in
Wales and even if it's true they get mad
go to the gym yeah yeah
I feel like you should feel like you're
beautiful you should feel like you're
that girl you're that guy you can do
anything that you put your mind to him
he can do it is he special are you
special sir
because a man has to work for his worth
a woman is born with her worth where did
you learn that
just watching different people talk
different podcasts
I don't know if you familiar with the
fresh and fit podcast but shout out
fresh and fit shout out fresh and fit
they talk about all that on there and
it's just it opens the mind up because
it's just it's what's happening like
females can take advantage of their
bodies and just off of how they look and
just take it off and a man can't do that
you know what I mean I mean for me like
I've always identified myself in
the sense of like what a feminist is in
terms of I believe in equality I I want
the same equal rights for everyone but I
kind of stumbled upon your videos I kind
of it really kind of opened my eyes to
like
this you know
um
all the things I've kind of been told
about like women need to be pumped up
they need all this extra stuff and I'm
it kind of peeled back that onion a bit
and kind of I was like I kind of want to
dive into this a bit more it kind of
opened my eyes to a new light of that so
that's more what kind of gravitated me
to your your stream was more it opened
my eyes in a way where I was like I feel
like I've been lied to a little bit
oh you feel like you've been lied to
yeah well just because you go out and
you're a man and it's uh you've got it
so easy uh you don't have to deal with
this you don't have to deal with that
and a lot of women don't realize what
especially like single men like if
you're a really attractive guy you've
got every girl hitting on you it's
really great but you know the average
guy spends a lot of time by himself
dealing with problems himself and until
he gets to that point of I'm successful
uh you know especially if you're not a
guy who's like what's that quote it's
six figure six foot and six inches all
that kind of stuff it's
um
yeah it's almost belittling as that
double standard and I I really don't
like it
um so I've really identified with a lot
of the points you make and it's really
helped me find a voice for things I
couldn't really put into words prior
they technically for the most part have
the power in the relationship so why do
you think women want equality in
everything except for dating
I think that goes back to like they just
don't want people to tell them what to
do like they just want control
think it's more about control and power
than equality
you know what I think it is because a
lot of the things that are when they're
equal
it's like okay well now you now we can
both do this we can both lift these
boxes and it's like no I want to lift
these boxes you go lift these boxes you
know
it's it's very it's very conditional
it's about what they want at that time a
lot of the questions that I ask on my
channel are often met with responses
like it goes both ways if it does go
both ways why do you think that women
dominate the mainstream media when it
comes to talking about women's issues
while men's content is forced to remain
online
I don't feel like it's equal at all
because women are more subjective to
their feelings and other women are more
subjective to their feelings you know
what I mean so it's just like a woman is
gonna feel bad for another woman but a
man is supposed to go through hard times
and go through the struggle to make his
success you know what I mean
I was just gonna say that
that's one thing that I don't understand
because we really do not pay attention
to men's mental health and things that
they go through we always worry about
women but men definitely go through too
I know it's not easy for a woman but
it's definitely not easy for a man as
well so I feel like it should be equally
you know but it's just like like that's
the thing like
even though me and you treat it like
that a lot of people don't like a lot of
people don't see
as is see it as equal because I a lot of
especially a lot of females feel like
a man should
prioritize
their like their woman first before
anything and a man is supposed to be the
front line of defense like
if a man like a woman's supposed to like
a woman all right a woman looks for a
traditional man right without being a
traditional woman
and
a woman is so quick to say something
about what a man is supposed to do and
what a man is not supposed to do but
what is a woman supposed to do you know
what I mean well why do you think that
women enjoy all the things uh that are
traditional when it comes to dating and
courtship but then a lot of
old-fashioned values women often label
to be sexist yeah that's a good one
um
because some people just want their cake
and eat it too and that's the problem do
you think that women are more likely to
have their cake into two or men are
as human beings we're programming like
that so if you give me the opportunity
to have cake and eat it I'm gonna eat it
can can you name any double standards in
relationships that benefit men
not much I mean
I'm probably not going to be able to
think of any right now but I know
there's probably something I could tell
you one the sleeping around I'd say
that's a double standard but other
outside of that I don't I've done the
show for months I I that's the only one
I could think of yeah I think that's a
that's one right
um but that usually comes from some type
of
displeasure in the relationship I think
if you're genuinely happy and content
you're not going to step out I think
when you step out is because there's
something lacking yeah I think so too
and a lot of times like girls don't
sleep with the guys they're dating or
their husband one of four marriages are
sexless so it's like do you think do you
think that men should be blamed for
cheating if she's not sleeping with him
you're not giving your husband or
partner
sex which is a major part and I know
some people say oh sex is not that big
of a deal [ __ ] kick the kick the
Rocks
um if you're not giving it and you're
using it as a weapon then I don't think
you should then be upset or disappointed
when that person steps out it's like if
I have a child and I'm not feeding my
child or I'm not nurturing him and
taking care of him if he goes to the
neighbor and the neighbors cooking him
meals as a parent yeah I'm gonna be
upset but logically I shouldn't be
because I'm not doing my responsibility
do you guys think women in general care
about men's problems
at face value yes in reality no
I I would say absolutely no
um
so why do you think that our society
labels women to be more nurturing if
they're really not empathetic to men's
issues
that's interesting that's a good way of
putting that
um
I'm not well versed on this stuff sorry
believe in mental health you can as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible